let us think that we are now moving into
a new era I'm Tracy Oppenheimer freezing
TV I'm here so we are the future alley
where thousands of Ron Paul supporters
have come out to hear his closing
remarks for the 2012 campaign there is
no next ron paul ron paul is one of a
kind we all make a commitment right now
to get involved numbers do count and
even numbers do count when they don't
caught all the votes as well because we
do have the numbers Ron Paul just filled
the sundome here in Tampa after
listening to that speech do you feel
like his fans and supporters are
rejuvenated to read just sort of the
feeling in the room it didn't feel huge
at the end you know it didn't feel a
triumphant and it didn't even actually
even feel like an n let us think that we
are now moving into a new era a new era
where we're going to concentrate on
liberty and freedom and property and
peace I believe that is the cause that
we should lead and I thank you very much
for being part of it thank you this was
not supposed to be this is all over
let's celebrate what we've done it was
supposed to be you need to think of ways
to carry these ideas forward in moving
forward who can we look forward to carry
on these type of views oh well anyone
with a conscience would be good it would
be great but he's done in the last four
last three or four years this movement I
think has to keep it needs somebody a
standard berenis his son why do all
these young people love Ron Paul why
does the internet love Ron Paul they
think it's because he's cool well you
know I'm his kid I can tell you it's not
because he's cool Ron Paul likes to
spread the message look this is not just
about electoral politics if you know the
answers and you speak out and and you're
available somebody will use you and and
it may be in politics you may run for
office you may organize who knows what
it'll be whether it be running for a
Republican precinct committee chair or
you know continuing to blog angrily
about government depredations or
just drive around with signs decrying
the [ __ ] everybody kind of is trying to
figure out where we're going to go but
it's definitely not just about ron paul
it's about his message and the message
of liberty and freedom and i think more
and more people are waking up to that I
have met too many people with too great
a level of enthusiasm to believe that
they're all going to fizzle away it is
not in the poll we have too many
supporters here does not emit fo long
haul has brought so many people into the
movement that will just virgin really
can't be stopped i don't think